with its new ex class mercedes is
breaking into a segment the German
carmaker has never tried before in a bid
to attract new customers to the brand
that's it yes the car tester says it's
the first of its kind until now
mercedes-benz had never built a pickup
truck that changes with the ex class its
brawny white enough for a shipping pilot
in the back and sturdy enough to go
off-road
this time we'll test drive the
production version Mercedes already
showed off its ex class concept truck at
the Geneva Motor Show last spring its
aggressive design caught everyone's
attention with a huge grille slender
headlights and flared wheel wells
unfortunately the production version is
tame by comparison
two person plaintiff says what jumps out
are the Mercedes star in the radiator
grille the massive bumpers and the wide
toe more than 1.6 meters both front and
rear this not only gives the ex class of
beefy appearance it also helps to
stabilize the pickup on the highway
off-road the ex classes ground clearance
of more than 20 centimeters helps it
stay out of trouble a centimeter a
striking feature is the ex classes
grille the production version has larger
headlights than the concept
in the rear the x-class boasts of
vertical taillights and a massive bumper
final says pickups have to be tough
whether they're going offroad or hauling
heavy loads the ex class can carry up to
1.1 tons on its bed and tow up to 3.5
tons the tailgate alone can withstand up
to 150 kilograms but despite all these
talents the two-ton truck drives almost
like a car
the new ex class offers a choice of two
diesel engines we tested the more
powerful 140 kilowatt version Mercedes
rates fuel consumption at 7.8 liters for
every 100 kilometers the truck emits 207
grams of carbon dioxide per kilometer
and the top speed is 175 kilometers per
hour
final says the ex class is more
comfortable than its competitors a big
plus on longer journeys what's unusual
for Mercedes is the conventional hand
brake and automatic gear selector lever
mounted on the center tunnel typical for
Mercedes are the air vent nozzles in the
dashboard in fact the ex class looks
very refined for an SUV what's more it
seats five people
and as luxurious as its interior is the
pickup can handle rough terrain with
ease
I know says it's time to see what the ex
class can do off road to find out we
took it to a special test track the ice
class faces a tough climb and waged
through water up to sixty centimeters
deep a 25 degree descent and 30 degree
climb are sufficient for most
construction sites and the boat ramp at
the lake all variants of the pickup come
with rear-wheel drive and manual 6-speed
gearbox as standard switchable 4matic
four-wheel drive is available at a
surcharge for all engine types the
7-speed automatic is only available with
the current top model the ex 250 D which
we're testing
or see these Christian pulses the
x-class is a real-life rotor and a real
pickup so 4matic is the perfect
all-wheel drive system for off-road use
for more challenging terrain it offers
ear reduction as well as a differential
lock and that really pulls it through
just about anywhere and there's more
power on the way for the ex class next
year Mercedes plans to roll out a
version powered by a 190 kilowatt 3
liter diesel v6
my note says the Mercedes x-class adds
new momentum to the pickup sector
technically the ex class is a close
relative of the Nissan Navara it's built
in the sameness on factory in Barcelona
but the Navara is around 10000 euros
cheaper he says he wishes the ex class
would have looked like the concept truck
at the Geneva Motor Show Auto Salon in
Kent
focused at hub but even if the pickup
could have been a bit more daring in its
design this latest Mercedes model is
still bound to turn heads wherever it
goes
you